a spirit is everywhere spirits the water
spirit is the land spirit is the animals
you know it's not empty there's no such
thing as an empty earth empty land as
the spirits are still learned so that
energy still learned that life to me to
describe it personally it's my home
being welcomed and invited by the First
Nations people who lived here for
hundreds of years
as really important to me and they chose
to do that with smudging ceremony which
gave me the blessing to be here and
explore this land
[Music]
the purpose this trip has have been
explore Wahb Akemi Provincial Park we
flew in this backcountry flow plane it
was absolutely incredible looking out
how fast this train was it was just
never-ending Lakes and boreal forests
the plane set us down so lightly I
didn't even feel the the water or the
landing it was a pretty wild feeling
watching the plane leave and realizing
that you know we're out here the canoe
is like the vessel to experience and
participate in all the activities you
can do here there's incredible camping
there's amazing fishing we're seeing
wildlife all around my friend rush
Sturges who's here during the filming is
a really good paddler both Eric and I
have whitewater backgrounds as
professional characters that it's kind
of funny that neither of us have
actually ever been in a canoe and we are
on the hunt for brook trout right now
okay rolling on all that neither one of
us had ever really knut at all
[Music]
[Music]
just to get to be in the wilderness and
to travel and the camp is incredible the
dichotomy of wha bikini is that not only
do you have these super authentic remote
campsites you also roll into these
really luxury lodges where you're
completely taken care of
[Music]
to me the thing that I appreciate the
most about this place is the culture and
the rich history that's here and the
completely untouched the natural it made
the place come alive
[Music]